andrean Alice doesn't have it easy the
SPD's general secretary is heading up
her party's campaign but it seems to be
falling flat she doesn't have to worry
too much here in Berlin though this is
home turf in a district rathaus a
traveling exhibit spans 150 years of SPD
history now list looks at her parties
story with pride and irony yes please
email the SPD is always somehow a bit
irrational when you calculate all the
hours we spend sitting in pointless
meetings in Windows Vista bling but it's
irrational in a good sense and I hope a
big win for our country too so Hoffa
issue a slant I'm ender and cause a
cave-in during the campaign the Social
Democrats have focused on issues like
justice fair wages better pensions and
transparency issues that speak to most
Germans yet somehow the party still
trails significantly in polls uber is
the SPD when it comes to issues we're
ahead still the voters like our
Chancellor but are frustrated with the
government and they still haven't made
the connection between those two points
we have to make clear who exactly is
responsible for the way the government
works the face of the party is para
Steinbrueck the SPD candidate for
Chancellor he's supposed to take his
message directly to the voters whether
it's over coffee or special edition
steps
Steinbrueck is keen to be the next
Chancellor but he's not exactly winning
hearts and minds taking part in theater
stunts like this one where he lies in a
tub full of plastic balls hasn't helped
it in all five values i hold ahead now
i'm down but it'll go up again shine
brooke has been touring the country for
weeks Hosting something the party calls
plain language with pear Steinbrueck he
says it's easy to see why the SPD isn't
winning with its campaign issues the
Chancellor is appropriating their ideas
and putting her own mark on them pocono
sorry I'm objetive Holyfield you can say
that lazy people always wait till the
last minute you have to expose what the
label on the bottle says and what's
actually inside with them what's on the
bottle is often not what's inside
there's usually no content that's the
difference that's the audition a minimum
wage is one of the SPD's biggest themes
under the party's plan all employers
should pay at least eight euros 50 an
hour guaranteed anything else is too
little they say the CDU is countering
with a proposed wage floor it sounds
like a minimum wage but it's not
employers wouldn't actually be obligated
to adhere to the lower limit it's like
window seats ocean there's a difference
between a wage floor and a legal minimum
wage it's not just the amount but also
the way it's implemented there are still
people or say if there's a wage floor
it's like a minimum wage and that's
enough of the administer medicine
when it comes to pensions the SPD wants
to institute a solidarity system whereby
every person who has reached pensionable
age gets at least eight hundred fifty
euros a month the CDU on the other hand
wants a merit-based system that would
boost monthly income for struggling
pensioners who have paid into the system
for years but it's not clear how much
help they get this is 45 and team it's a
tactic to take issues reformulate them
and own them on that way you end up
demobilizing some of the SPD's
supporters it's a strategy the SPD
hasn't really been able to answer yet
Deeb is here kind of icky God vodka for
not under Ian Ollis has her own approach
she believes if voters aren't able to
see the clear difference between her
party and the Conservatives she'll have
to explain it to them personally the
allman swollen or planning to go
door-to-door to millions of homes to
talk directly with citizens we can still
mobilize the vote and that's what we're
going to do notice van Gogh tuned less
than six months remain until the
elections still time for the SPD to win
over as many voters as they can